hello
and congratulations on the films of both
of
you
thank you so first off a question for
both of you
in general what is the very first thing
that you usually do when you get a new
script
or a new project and if anything what
was unique to your early prep work on
promising young woman
i learned the lyrics to stars are blind
by paris hilton that was a sort of
unique
friend that printed those out and tried
to figure them out
um gosh this was so this was so much
one of those things where it wasn't a
lot of kind of solo prep work for me it
was lots of sort of
chat there was lots of conversation
there was lots of talking to emerald
and we had a really nice couple of days
of sort of meeting
um you know various cast and like
reading through stuff and talking about
it and so it felt like quite a kind of
ensemble
rehearsal period slash kind of
preparation so none of it felt like
it wasn't a lot for me it wasn't a lot
of kind of going away and thinking about
things alone it was lots of like talking
things out
um which was really helpful once you
know emerald said yes we want you to do
the film i sent this script to my acting
coach
and then i met with her and we talked
about it
and we did some scene work did we do
a private moment for gail i don't think
if we did but we did a lot of i've
worked with my coach on it i've been
working with him her name is kimberly
harris
i've been working with kimberly for many
years now so i
um it's i found it useful now because
i'm doing so
many other things that like my work with
her
specifically has helped to just kind of
focus me and she
sees things that i don't always see um
which is i found
really wonderful so yeah i sent it to um
kimberly and then we
we met you know a few times and talked
about it and worked through some things
i'm sorry a a private moment is it is
that just developing a private moment
for
your character on the side that isn't in
the film just for for prep
oh yeah it's an acting school thing i'm
like getting all like acting school
thing
yeah i've done a character private
moment is when you
sort of create in different studios do
it in different ways but one the way
i've been taught and the way i do with
kimberly is that we sort of create
it's about creating a moment of privacy
and intimacy moment with the character
and you get information
valuable information that's not about
the script at all it's not about what
happens on the script it's often
backstory it's historical
um there are activities that you do as
the character
that are usually involved eating
something drinking something some sort
of activity
but it's really about finding the
intimacy and the privacy of the
character and you're getting
valuable information that then you can
bring to
layer in underneath the work that you um
that you do on set you know um with with
the other actors so it's like the
layering
back story kind of filling in the blank
so they just experienced and lived and
not just an idea
this might be a good but kind of broad
follow-up that doesn't really have one
clear-cut answer
but i'm curious what is your approach to
working on a supporting character in a
way that
supports the main character's arc in the
story at hand but also
makes her feel like a fully realized
person which i think you will accomplish
here
what's fun about this is getting to
watch
carrie work as well as sort of interact
with her and then listening to emerald
and bo
and just sort of being in the space you
know you do all the prep
ideally so you can let it go and be in
the moment so i think the support
really is about hopefully i mean
if it ideally it's always about
supporting the other actor you're with
whether you're a lead character or a
supporting character so it's really
about listening and being in the moment
and and doing what is necessary in that
moment as much as possible hopefully
from a sense of truth and a sense of um
telling the story did you two ever
work out any backstory for your
characters i just find that i always
wonder about those things when i just
really want to continue spending time in
that space and i could have done that in
the coffee shop so did you uh
talk about any of their history together
with emerald yeah i think we just
thought you know we decided that
she you know cassie definitely worked
there for a while um
and that you know really gail's her only
friend
um and that that she really is the only
person that she has any kind of
relationship with and i think
you know uh there's a there's a kind of
comfort there that she doesn't have with
anybody else and i think that's fostered
by just
gail being a really solid noble [ __ ]
person
um who can be honest with her in a way
that not very many other people can and
also isn't intimidated by her
which i think cassie's very good at kind
of like shutting lots of people out and
i think gail
just sort of sees through that and
doesn't you know there's no kind of
intimidation she can just deal with
whatever
um so i think that sort of
and what i found so um
helpful about laverne's performance as
gail
was the freedom that she had in playing
her
and the fact that when i walked into the
coffee shop and we started shooting the
scenes and it was like the second day of
filming
so you're still kind of feeling your way
in um it felt like
her coffee shop it was her it was like a
very lived in
space even though it was like a set that
we literally just walked onto the second
day of filming
it felt like such an inhabited character
and that this coffee shop
belonged to gail and laverne was fully
inhabiting that character and was
very very free to the point where she
was able to just like
improvise lines and start scenes in
different ways and end scenes in
different ways and
i think that coming in and doing that as
a supporting
character is incredibly difficult and
does take that like preparation to be
able to come in and just do it and
for it to feel like so effortless i feel
like you could feel that quality when
you watch the film
um terry you also have a great
opportunity here to work with
like an endless ensemble of fantastic
people
so of everyone in the movie whose
process would you say aligned with yours
the most and then who
challenged you to adapt the most me
yeah uh gosh who i guess
probably alfred molina and i had worked
together before
he played my father in an education and
so it was so much fun to get to work
with him again and i think
um uh there was sort of that was kind of
nostalgic in a nice way and
um so i felt like i knew how he worked
and we
you know so i guess we worked in a
similar way um and similarly
actually working with connie as well um
was was somewhat like i think we sort of
work in a similar way i think working
with laverne
and beau and you know um
sam richardson was so much fun for me
because you know i was really surrounded
by people who whether they were
comedians or they were just very
adept at comedy like laverne i would
come as like a dramatic actress who's
incredibly adept
at comedy um it just kept me on my toes
in a way that like
was so exciting because i haven't been
in a film where i've been surrounded by
so many people who can do that um
and uh so that was really fun and
totally different from how i
you know my experience of film and i
remember even like the second day of
filming saying to beau like i can't
believe
how much i'm laughing like i never lost
this much at work i love my job and i've
loved the films that i've done but they
haven't been like funny they've been
kind of white
um so it was just really nice to do
something where there was like a levity
you know even though we were dealing
with a difficult subject like there was
a lot of laughter on set
how about uh getting that through
emerald what can she do as kind of the
leader on set to
you know not only set a tone where
you're enjoying the work that you're
creating despite the subject matter but
also
where you're exploring this subject
matter in a way that feels fully
safe well i mean i think
you know i i had complete faith in
emeralds from the moment we met
but there was one thing that she was
very clear on that sort of set
sort of in my mind i i knew that
the rest of the film would sort of be
would follow this order so we were
talking
really it was like the first meeting we
ever had we were talking about the um
the stripping scene you know when she
when cassie goes to the um
the party addresses the nurse and um
and em was sort of describing how the
scene would go down and she would go in
and she put the bottle down and she was
talking me through the whole thing and
then she said and then she reaches for
her zip
and then the camera turns on the men and
then you never see anything you just see
their reactions to it
and that's kind of how she handled the
whole
film there was you never there was
nothing ever i never felt
and similarly to cassie i think there's
very little you know in the film where
cassie's not completely in control
um she's you know under the guise of
being someone who's out of control she's
completely in control
um and so i think you know it was all
very considered and thought through so i
think there was sort of
yeah it felt like a very um that all
felt completely safe
also it was she's just so funny emerald
she's just one of the funniest people
and she's
like a joy as a leader you know because
she's hilarious and
um and so the crew loved her and all the
actors love her and
um so it was very kind of the the set
was just fun
and light and we took it seriously when
we needed to how about for you liver and
what's something unique to emerald's
process that you wish you saw more sets
out there
i've been very lucky in my career that
i've worked with a lot of women and i've
worked with a lot of women directors
but emerald is as carrie said she's
hilarious
she's so genuinely funny
and just infectious and i
like want to hang out with her like all
the time it's like this
like emerald is just so such a good time
that like and so there's such a
she very naturally puts everyone at ease
and so there's a safety in that
and but there's she manages to be really
funny
um but like fully in control and in
command
of everything as well and so she's
handling things
and is on top of everything in a
brilliant way but there's so much fun
with it
um so i think that sense of fun um but
there but a bit of clarity too of the
vision
so that she's she wrote it so but
there's a crystal
she's crystal clear about what she wants
and needs in a moment
so that that kind of clarity gives
me and as an artist and room to play
like
to to understand where we're going and
then to
find ways to sort of um live um in the
character and
while going for whatever it is that that
we're going for in a scene or in a
moment
thank you guys so much for your time
today and again big congratulations